the diplomatic rift between the US and
Britain is growing wider over
embarrassing leaked cables critical of
President Trump British ambassador Kim
Derrick was uninvited from a dinner the
president attended last night earlier
mr. Trump said the US would no longer
deal with Derrick in the cables the
Ambassador called the Trump
administration inept Ben Tracy is at the
White House Ben Britain is supposed to
be our closest ally how big a deal is
this well the president is clearly
annoyed and the British government is
launching an investigation into who
leaked these memos now they say that the
UK says its ambassadors are supposed to
be candid that they're supposed to send
their thoughts back to British officials
but the content of these leaked memos is
painfully blunt in one of them
ambassador Kim Derrick writes we don't
really believe Trump's administration is
going to become substantially more
normal less dysfunctional less
diplomatically clumsy and inept in
another he says president Trump radiates
insecurity now the president responded
Monday on Twitter saying the Ambassador
is not liked or well thought of within
the US and then bluntly said we will no
longer deal with him outgoing Prime
Minister Theresa May says she still
supports Derek but the British
government says it is made clear to the
US how unfortunate all of this is it
does come at a critical time when both
the US and the UK face a new threat from
Iran which just yesterday further
exceeded its uranium enrichment cap
bringing it closer to developing a
nuclear weapon now after the u.s. pulled
out of that nuclear deal the remaining
European members have been trying to
keep Iran in side the agreement Anthony
meanwhile been the president gave a
speech yesterday boasting about his
administration's environmental record
how does this record actually measure up
well the President did position himself
as a champion of the environment he said
that the US can really lead on fighting
air in water pollution around the world
but keep in mind it was the president
that pulled out of the Paris climate
Accord and has overseen sweeping
rollbacks of air and water protections
now the president previously called for
the Environmental Protection Agency to
be eliminated which is why some green
groups are calling his speech yesterday
utter
we should also point out that during
that 20 minute speech there were two
words that the president never said and
those words are climate change Anthony
all right then thank you very much